let's say you have a big new piece of
property but you can only choose one
machine which one do you choose well i
can't make that decision for you but i
can go through some of the pros and cons
i know a lot of you guys have made this
same tough decision but leave your
comments down below as we walk through
these five machines i'll give you my
take on it all and if i had to sell all
these off and keep just one i'll let you
know what it is at the end hey when
you're done watching if you enjoyed the
video i'd love to get a thumbs up from
you hit subscribe to see more tractor
and maybe property development videos
too and if you want something for your
tractor or your skid steer make sure you
check out goodworkstractors.com
okay
hang on look at those deer
one two three four
five one two there's five one though
that's a doe
that's a doe little guy
all right we'll give you the quick
rundown of what equipment we have here
first we're gonna start with the sub
compact tractor gonna have a john deere
1025 r loader has a backhoe has a belly
mower on it
next to it right here we're gonna have a
john deere 333g skid steer but just
think of this as a skid steer in general
they make them big they make them small
they make them with tracks and with
wheels all sorts of stuff but a skid
steer represented right here next up
we're going to have a very large compact
tractor this is as big of a compact
tractor as you can get a hydrostatic
machine you can get a backhoe for it you
can get the front end loader forward a
cab and open station 66 horsepower so
representative kind of the flip flop
side of the 1025r which is the smallest
subcompact tractor you can get with the
biggest compact right here next up we
have this bad boy i just got this one in
a kubota m4d-071
yeah that's a mouthful but this is going
to be into the utility frame size or
classification of tractors the next step
up from the compact so we have
subcompact skid steer compact utility
all right so this is a whole other gamut
we'll get into that soon and last but
not least we're gonna have the cat 305
e2 this is a mini excavator
so far i haven't used this one a whole
lot but i've got a lot of projects for
it
there's going to be some pros and cons
associated with each one of these pieces
of equipment so let's get into it now
all right let's get started but
i want to put this out there i know
there will be comments the right machine
could depend on your property right the
size of your property if you have fields
ponds woods whatever you have going on
your budget a lot of variables come into
play so i'm giving you this information
from my perspective based on my property
about 140 acres
a mixture a field a lot of woods a lot
of pond frontage a lot of hills so this
is a tailor-made decision for my
property
all right well i've said this a lot of
times about a 1025 r it's small but it's
mighty you know 140 acres is a pretty
big chunk of land for a small tractor
like this but it can technically do a
lot of the work that needs to be done
out here it's just going to take it a
lot longer you know a really good
example would be we're putting in an
1800 foot long driveway and i had been
using a bigger a seven foot tiller on my
4720 for a while but then that broke
down for a bit of time and
needed to keep the work going so we
hooked up a four foot tiller on the 10
25 r it just
takes a while longer you know it's a
smaller footprint you have to go slower
it doesn't want to tilt as deep but the
point being you can still get the job
done if time allows the same thing could
be said for mowing a big old field
tilling a food plot putting some trails
in through the woods there's a lot of
things that you can actually do with
this tractor but there's a lot of big
projects out there that i have no desire
to tackle with a tractor this size
another big benefit that i found with a
smaller tractor is when i'm in the woods
which again is a huge portion of this
property trying to maintain those trails
or just navigate them or if you're
trying to turn around in tight quarters
a smaller machine is just obviously
easier to use and where we're standing
right now i hope someday will be the
yard of our future home and with a
tractor this size you can put a
mid-mount mower or a belly mower on it
and maintain your lawn so
if you're looking for an all-in-one
machine that can do it all maybe you do
have a little bit smaller chunk of land
then this could garner some serious
consideration but tractors in general
are known as swiss army knives right
they can just do a little bit of
everything you know with the front end
loader you can put a bucket a snow
pusher a grapple a set of pallet forks
you can get a backhoe on the back side
of course the belly mower underneath
they can just tackle all sorts of
different projects that may come up
which really enhances their value and i
think it's important to note that this
is really just the miracle of hydraulics
so to speak so everything from the
hydraulic transmissions to just have a
twin touch pedal system to go forwards
and backwards out changing gears is
amazing you know with the hydraulics
that can lift a thousand or more pounds
you know and just dig holes and do
everything that these machines do is
just incredible in and of itself as well
as their ability to enhance your life
all right moving on to a skid steer i
tell you i have spent a lot of hours
over the last few months in my skid
steer we bought the property at the end
of june it's now november
a lot of heavy lifting was required this
was a completely overgrown property
wild for years and years and years and
so it took a lot of effort to get it to
this point where we're at right now and
still needs a lot more work to get where
we want to go so i have upgraded this is
the largest of the john deere skid
steers that are out there or ctls
compact track loaders that you might
hear it called but this is kind of the
top of the heap and you could get a
smaller skid steer and still be
well ahead of some other capabilities on
other pieces of equipment the hydraulic
systems on skid steers are
top notch and if you get a high flow
system it's going to allow you to get
into something like a multihead which i
used out here for hours and hours and
hours on end to create trails these
fields were just riddled with autumn
olive and other overgrown bushes and i
just spent days clearing everything out
cleaning it up we still have more work
to do on the other side of the property
too but if i were to sum up a skid steer
in one word it would be power and it's
just
the ability to do whatever you want if
you have to move logs if you want to use
that mulcher head if you need to lift
heavy things with a set of pallet forks
you can count on a skid steer to get it
done now second right behind the power
aspect for me on a hilly property is
going to be the stability that this
sense of
safety that you feel in a skid steer it
has a low center of gravity these are
nice wide tracks i mean it's
i don't know it's just an incredible
feeling compared to a tractor and i'm
not picking on the 10 25 it's just
tractors in general they're pretty long
and they're skinny and they have a
little bit higher center of gravity so
you're really going to notice an uneasy
tippy feeling you know we've talked
about bora for a long long time and and
adding wheel spacers to widen your
footprint and the reason for that is
because it is just an unsettling feeling
they had this roll bar up top here to
prevent rollovers from occurring because
it killed so many people years ago now
of course the skid steer is still going
to have a roll cage on it i mean that's
just a safety thing you're going to see
on any piece of equipment these days but
i tell you i have never felt uneasy or
tippy at all in my skid steer i guess
i'm just not pushing it hard enough so
as far as attachments go everything is
going to go on the front end loader so
no matter what you're hooking up you can
put a tiller on a skid steer if you want
to but it's going right up here in front
same thing with that brush mulcher same
thing with a set of paddle forks
whatever you want to do whereas a tiller
is going to go on the back side on the
three-point hitch on a tractor but what
i really like about that is the
visibility i mean you can see this whole
glass door everything is right there in
front of you it's super easy to see
on a tractor you've got the the hood the
cowling the engine compartment all in
the way so it can be difficult to see
what's in front of you of course if you
have something on the three-point hitch
you can turn around and see behind you
but that does get uncomfortable after a
while now as far as the prices these
attachments go a lot of these are going
to be hydraulically driven some are
going to have hydraulic motors on there
there's no like pto shaft so there's no
gearbox like what a tractor could have
on a three-point hitch on the back side
so the attachments can get really costly
along with the fact that these larger
hydraulic systems have more capacity so
they need to be built beefier stouter
more steel which just means more cost
and now besides the attachments skid
steers themselves can cost a pretty
penny you know so you don't have to get
the biggest and the baddest one out
there you can get something smaller you
can get an open station
out here oh boy i tell you i would not
get a wheeled skid steer at least for
this property it was like just spinning
your wheels uh literally i mean there's
still ruts that that i've seen around
here that we had when we were first out
here
these tracks are amazing out here on the
property and i can't imagine having a
wheeled steer
[Music]
now before we get started on the 4720 i
think it is worth noting that
all these machines have a factory cab on
them with air conditioning and heat with
the exception of the 1025r which they
don't offer now you can get a cab with
heat on the 1025r and take the doors off
in the summertime and have a little
fresh breeze coming through that's fine
but if you have a cab on your tractor or
your skid steer or whatever the heck it
is in summer winter you know if it's
dusty out if it's rainy if it's snowy if
it's hot if it's cold whatever it is
you're going to get a lot more work done
a lot more efficiently a lot more
comfortably you're going to stay out
there longer your projects will get done
quicker you see where i'm going with
this okay now onto the 4720 or the 4066
like what i had previously to this
machine but this is a large frame
compact tractor as big as you can get
why that's significant to me is that
this is still going to be a hydrostatic
machine all right so you have a ton of
lift capacity on the front end loader
and on the three-point hitch to really
tackle large attachments and projects
that you need to do but you can still do
it efficiently with a hydrostatic
transmission which going forward and
backwards is a piece of cake compared to
a gear drive which we'll get into that
soon on this machine but there's really
a whole list of pros and cons between
hydro and gear drive in general that's
not really what this is about but really
a hydro transmission is hard to be if
you're going to be changing direction a
lot say you're going into a a pile of
material or you're grappling a lot of
logs just going back and forth with
different loader applications and
functions
it's just really hard to beat so really
this has the same type of versatility as
the 1025r we talked about earlier well
with the exception of mowing your lawn
you're really not going to mow your lawn
with this tractor too often it's pretty
darn big for that but
a good example would be mowing this
field right so we did some mowing with
several different machines and on a 1025
r you could run a 48 inch a four foot
brush hog but we're running a 10 foot
brush we could run a 12 or 15 foot if we
wanted to on this tractor so you can see
how having a lot bigger tractor can help
you be a lot more efficient if you have
a large acreage application and this
isn't every tractor series that's out
there there's a big jump from a 1 series
to a 4 series you have the 2 and the 3
series in the middle and you could fall
well within that range too just
depending on the size of the land that
you have or the size of the projects or
the size of attachments or the budget or
whatever it is but we're just talking
about the machines that i have out here
at the property right now and so i have
used this tractor a decent amount out
here so far and i would have used it
more if it wasn't for the whole
overheating experience i had this summer
but we've done some field mowing with it
we've done some driveway maintenance
actually we used the tiller to help put
the driveway in as well did some
landscape raking over on the other side
of the property too and we originally
got a four series tractor to use back at
the shop just to help offload and load
up trucks and pallets and move things
around it's a very capable machine it's
very stable we added some wheel spacers
on to make it a little bit wider
probably didn't really need to so much
out here it's a little hilly so it does
come in handy but these are naturally a
pretty stable machine
[Music]
all right well this is the latest
addition to my fleet here which is a
kubota
m4d-071 this is a utility tractor all
right so we're stepping out of the
compact world stepping up into the
utility world you can see it's a bigger
footprint bigger tires heavier still has
a front end loader on it still has a
three-point hitch still has a cab you're
not going to mow your lawn with this but
one of the main reasons that i got this
tractor was for that kind of just point
it in one direction and go type of work
so if you are brush hogging a big field
or if you are grading your long driveway
or if you're
plowing a field you know if you're just
doing something where you just kind of
set it and forget it this is a great
machine for it you know i'm actually
going to be setting this up with a big
old snow pusher on it to plow the
driveway so same kind of application
right it's not the loader work where
you're digging into a pile and going
back and forwards all the time or trying
to grade and smooth things out with your
bucket i did not get this tractor to do
that kind of work but it really got me
thinking about a bigger gear drive
tractor when we had some overheating
issues when we were brush talking this
summer you know it was 90 degrees plus
out all summer long and the hydra
machines will run a little warmer and as
we found out they will overheat and then
if you're in a pandemic it's going to
take you six or eight weeks to get your
tractor back up and running i just don't
want to deal with that nonsense anymore
so yeah i used to have a 5115m which is
115 horsepower 5 series tractor i bought
that because i got a great deal on it
and i thought i'm going to use that
someday at a new property i get out here
though i don't have enough open acreage
to really justify a tractor that big
it's a whole new set of attachments
where this is a 73 horsepower tractor so
it's just a few horsepower bigger than
the 4 series tractor so i can use a lot
of those similar size attachments that i
already sell and carry but i can use
this for certain applications it can run
a lot cooler
it's going to be efficient when i'm just
mowing a field i'm not changing
direction having to switch gears and
monkey around with all that so since i
don't have to choose one piece of
equipment i bought this to tackle a
certain set of needs a certain set of
projects
and to make videos for you guys you know
i think it's worth noting as well that
you are actually going to get a little
bit more stable with this tractor again
it's a wider footprint your center of
gravity really isn't going up much
higher so it's about seven foot wide
compared to about six foot wide on the
four series so you're just going to
notice on those smaller tractors like
the 1 series all the way up to the 2 3 4
5 6 series whatever it is you're
naturally going to feel a little bit
more
safe and secure the larger you go
all right and last but not least is
going to be the mini excavator and
man i've watched a lot of youtube videos
of folks using these things and they are
just amazing for a lot of different
projects which i'm going to get to out
here i haven't really used it a whole
lot just yet but again it's man it's
tough to find equipment right now so if
you're browsing around and you find what
you think is a good deal you better just
jump on it and that's what i did because
i know i have a lot of needs coming up
for this so we have four thousand foot
of pond frontage you know with some
really steep banks there and angles and
a lot of areas that it's going to be
unsafe and unstable to take other
equipment just to get the
the fallen branches and logs and trees
that have accumulated there so just to
get everything cleared out clean that
edge up a bit we have a driveway to put
over on the other side of the property
about another eight or 900 foot drive
got to get a nice connecting road from
this side to the other side as well so a
lot of stumps to remove some some hills
to cut into the sides and really grade
them out you know culver's to put in
there's a lot of different applications
you can use a mini x4 but think about
this you know this is this is one tool
this is a backhoe essentially that you
can put on the back of a tractor you
know any of those tractors we talked
about of course different sizes and
going to be less capable you know you
can get a backhoe actually for the front
or an excavator for the front of the
skid steer if you wanted to but this is
a dedicated
excavator right that's all this is going
to do yes you can put
like a mulcher head on here if you
wanted to do some forestry mulching with
it you can get a few other attachments
to kind of build them out and open up
the versatility but it's going to be the
most limited as far as the spectrum of
work that can be done at least in my
opinion however i know there's some mini
x lovers out there so you're waiting to
prove me wrong tell me all the things i
can use this mini x for i want to know
all the projects i can do with it
[Music]
okay so now it's time to tell you if i
could only pick one which machine would
i choose now i am curious to know which
one you think i should keep
but the one that i would keep if i could
only keep one
would be the 4720. and ironically enough
this is actually the machine that i'm
going to be selling and really the
reason for that is it's going to be the
biggest compact tractor i can get so
it's hydrostatic which is just the ease
of operation and efficiency for me you
know i can have plenty of lift capacity
with the front end loader for logging
for grapple work for
three-point lift capacity as well
run large attachments with the pto
tackle everything i need to in the
comfort of a cab with heat and air
conditioning for a property this size
140 acres even if you had just 40 acres
i think that this is the tractor to get
at least a 4 series it doesn't have to
be the 4720 or the 4066 but this general
size of a tractor is very capable so but
this gets you out of the bigger utility
tractors and the gear drive something
that's a little bit more compact says
the name right
but you can get a kubota l6060 or
another grand l just for a similar
comparison in the kubota world but since
i'm not keeping just one machine this is
the one that's gonna go alrighty well
that's gonna wrap it up you know i am
curious what you guys have to say about
all this and believe it or not what you
say helps a lot of other folks out a lot
of folks read these comments down below
so do everybody a favor if you have
something helpful pitch in and leave a
comment but i do want to thank you for
taking the time to stop by today if you
did enjoy the video i'd love to get a
thumbs up from you hit that subscribe
button to see more tractor videos and if
you want something for your machine
tractor or a skid steer make sure you
check out goodworkstractors.com until
next time stay safe we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
you